To imagine like a police officer walking up to a car that's freaky enough.
You don't know what's inside.
That's like you're playing roulette.
You don't know what's inside that car.
You know,
like,
look,
there are some bad police out there.
But as just put yourself in that spot where you're a cop getting out your car,
walking to a car with tinted windows,
knocking on the window,
you don't know what you're going to kill.
No.
If it's a barrel of a shotgun,
you don't know.
You have no idea.
And people have to realize that that tension they carry with them all day,
they might have 20 of those interactions.
Absolutely.
All Day and,
and,
and a couple could've been really bad for.
Yeah.
And if you have you given them any bullshit or don't appreciate or respect that,
they're immediately going to go,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
he fucking asshole.
And you're the enemy now.
And it's horrible.
It's horrible that we give a person the kind of power that police officers have
when they abuse it.
But it's also horrible that we create this relationship between fellow citizens
of prep as a cop is just a citizen citizens,
just one of us where we are the enemy if we're not following the book,
especially when the book is stupid,
like it's pot laws or something dumb like that,
like,
or you're catching guys getting jerked off like Jesus Christ.
You know,
I've been pulled over a couple of times and I,
I got to say,
you know,
most of them,
like my dad,
you know,
they say a a black thing to do when you have a black father,
they tell you very early on when a cop pulls you over,
hands out,
let them see it.
You know,
it's taught to us when we're born and raised,
especially where I grew up.
So,
you know,
I even been profiled and I'm like,
like,
and I'm half black,
you know,
you don't know what I really am.
A lot of people,
but I've been profiled so I know when I see,
when I hear the stories and I've been in cars with my friends that are dark skin
black and they've been pulled over and it's a thing where you're upset because
you feel like you're being profiled.
But man,
what's that cop walks over.
You need to show all due respect because they,
they control that game now it's a 100% their gang,
once they pull up to your window,
you're in their cart.
Of course should think that they are entirely necessary for a civilized society,
100% and if you want to be able to call the police,
if some shit is going down,
you should appreciate them when they're there.
And you know,
this does not discount all the bad cops.
Yeah,
absolutely not discount.
All the things that we've all seen,
the shootings were unjustified punching.
They were on justified.
This is what we have to keep though perspective because there's so many
interactions.
There's so many cops out there that are dealing with PTSD all day long because
for a decade or two decades of their life,
they have been dealing with crime and violence all day long,
every day.
And they dress like the enemy.
They're not just a cop there capo as to where a cop outfit.
So everywhere you go,
like when you weren't playing quake and you play in teams to the hatchery goes
Kuwait dude has a special flag over his head.
You know that's a target.
I mean if you see,
if you see cops are like bad guys,
see cops as the enemy,
you're being paid to be the enemy.
Even if you've never had an interaction of euro bad guy and that's a cop,
that's the enemy.
And that is a crazy but position to ask people to be.
Even for people that don't have interactions with cops a lot,
they still considered the enemy.
Sure.
Cause if they pull you over for speeding like I,
it's gone through my mind.
It's like nobody's on the road right now.
Why are you pulling me over for speeding?
Like I'm not hurting anybody.
It's just a waste of time trying to write a ticket because they have to write a
certain amount of tickets.
And that's,
and that's when I think it goes over the top where it's like,
come on now.
I was talking to a cop about that.
I said,
okay,
no,
let me ask you this.
What if everybody agreed to never speed?
Like we made a like a six month agreement in this country where we would never
speed and no one speed it.
And there was no more traffic violations in terms of speeding tickets.
What the fuck would happen?
And he was like,
people would just get laid off left and right.
They would just,
yeah,
he just like,
I think they would just slash to the police department,
they put quotas on you cause you're a glorified revenue collector.
I mean,
that's what those,
don't you think that's a problem though?
Like when you're pulling people over,
and I think that it all looked the problems with the police and people start
from the core.
And that's a major problem if you have to pull over people,
even if you're a cop and go,
eh,
they're not really doing anything bad,
but I have to meet my quota of tickets that starts from a very negative place.
Terrible,
terrible place,
place.
Terrible place in,
terrible place for,
for both parties.
Terrible plays for the cop to bury his head in the sand and realize he's writing
someone a ticket for no reason.
You know,
like you catch someone speed limit 65 they're sick.
They're going 69 you pull them over like kit though.
Fuck,
I've really,
yeah.
You can't even pay attention.
Like there's no way,
unless I'm not looking at the road like it,
unless I have cruise control or I'm not looking at the road all,
I might get to 69 and my backup to 65 again,
even if I'm trying to go the speed limit,
but I know people that have been pulled over four miles over 100% yeah.
But as a driver of that car going four miles over,
you're pissed.
Yeah.
Like automatically checked.
You just got jacked in your mind.
Are protecting and we all know he's writing a ticket just to write a ticket.
It's probably the 27th or 28th of the month and they got to meet their quota and
he just put like,
that's where they drive driving to Vegas is the worst.
They set up traps and especially close to the end of the month,
you know,
if you're driving to Vegas,
go to speed limit because you're waiting for you.
I got pulled over by plane.
Oh have you seen this?
Go into Vegas.
They have planes that now radar you,
they don't even,
and then they send out cop cars,
pull your own radars,
you and then a cop car pulls you over lay.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
And that was the last time we went to Vegas.
I went with my wife and son and we got pulled like a cop car came out of
nowhere.
And my wife,
here's the difference,
you know the,
this shows that my wife is white from Wyoming.
Right?
And this is the big difference.
That's real white,
that that's why it's like pilgrim.
That's like Casper the friendly ghost white.
That's like cowboy,
white translucent.
I literally,
right.
Only cowboys up there.
Wyoming cowboys.
Yeah.
Did you,
your wife grew up on a ranch?
No.
Shit.
No,
no,
no.
I think the cities,
yeah,
they grew up in Gillette,
Gillette,
Wyoming.
Oh fuck.
Is that Gillette,
Wyoming people there?
I think 3000 come on.
Nah,
seriously.
They're like the Brady bunch.
I married into the Brady plan.
Like,
seriously,
they're real life,
right?
It's like,
good morning Michael.
How are you?
Like they are those peats Kinda cool.
No,
that's great.
So a cop pulls us over for this Vegas trip and this is the difference in
cultures we have.
And this is why I tried to tell my wife when the cop came over his name,
let's say officer Andrew,
he comes over,
I'm very polite.
I said,
yes sir,
you got it.
No problem.
I was speeding.
My wife and the cop goes,
we pulled you over by a plane.
So he gives me a ticket and I'm like,
hey officer,
have a great day.
See you too,
sir.
My wife is in the backseat with my son.
Rolls down the window when he's walking away and goes,
excuse me,
uh,
how do you know it was this black SUV?
I see lots of black SUV is passing us and it's from a plane.
Are you serious?
And I'm like,
I'm about to die.
The cop turns back around like comes to my side of the window and says,
excuse me Ma'am and it,
but just the privilege to be able to talk to a cop like that cause she has no
idea.
She has no idea.
That's the real white privilege.
That's the real one.
And I'm like,
hey.
And I'm like telling the car,
tell me about,
I'm telling the cop,
I'm saying,
hey baby,
it's okay.
I was speeding.
You can about this onstage.
No,
you fucking should.
I know,
Dude.
That's hilarious.
And I'm like,
you should for sure.
[inaudible] stage.
It's,
it's just,
it scared me because I was scared because she's the cop comes back around.
Write that down right now.
Okay,
Kate,
that pad,
write that down.
Write it down.
You must talk about this on stage.
Wife,
cop
life claim privilege,
plain radar,
black SUV,
Wyoming cowboy white people.
We've got a whole suite we got stang catch too.
So shoehorn soap,
horseshoe.
He comes back over and he's trying to explain to my wife like about a plane and
she's given this cop attitude.
Oh No.
Yeah.
Well we drive off.
I go,
baby,
you cannot do that.
Like you almost killed me.
She was like,
stop being ridiculous.
I'm like,
no,
no.
You really know.
You really could have gotten me killed.
You'd never,
never,
no wrong guy.
Wrong place.
Wrong time.
Wrong history,
wrong background,
wrong state of mind that he's in.
What if he didn't like a black dude?
Married to a white woman?
For sure.
Yeah.
Like,
and she didn't get that,
but now she gets that because we have a son.
You know what I mean?
So I think once you have a multi ethnic son,
now she's like,
oh,
I'm all about marijuana.
I'm all about,
she doesn't like,
she's all about the ethnic cartoons and not the white,
but she's trying,
she's trying.
She's got a good mindset.
Yes.
She's trying to inner families trying,
you know,
it sucks that anybody has to ever worry about getting accidentally shot by a
cop.
And the problem I think is not going to go away until the problem of crime goes
away.
And that's not going to happen either.
So what do we do to make life safer for everybody?
That's a real good fucking question.
Well,
I think awareness for sure.
Like people being aware of all these videos.
That's one thing that I think that black black lives matter did that people
don't want to accept,
but it's really important.
It's,
it became a national thought.
Yes.
It's not just another story in the news.
It's a national thought.
Like this is a movement to try to eradicate this.
And all the times where you've seen guys plant guns on people after they've
shot.
I'm like almost crazy videos.
Yeah.
You see videos of black people with no guns getting shot and then here's the
problem.
They go to court and then the cops are innocent.
You see the one where the guy throws the gun down on the ground or was it,
was it a taser?
What did he throw down on the ground?
There was like he shot him and then as he's coming up to the body,
he dropped something on the ground when I was growing up,
at least,
I don't know when it changed,
but cops were supposed to shoot,
not to kill you,
but to handicap you,
like shoot you in the leg,
shoots you in the arm.
She doesn't,
not that good a shot.
There's a lot of cops that are just not good at shooting guns.
I mean there's a lot that our military trained that are very professional and
very serious who are,
but it's like,
look,
I've watched a video the other day of a guy getting into altercations,
off duty.
Cop got into an altercation with this guy and he tried to pull his gun out.
The guy grabbed him,
grabbed his risk.
I did not know how to fight at all and probably only knew how to shoot people.
He gets taken down.
The Guy,
obviously new Jujitsu took.
We took them down,
mounted them,
took the gun from him,
threw the gun away and beat the fuck out of them from the mount pound doc.
I turns his back.
He gets his back.
He's beating the shit out of them.
It's horrific because this cop thought he was safe and pulled his gun.
But this isn't like one example of like,
just because someone's a cop doesn't mean they're a well trained,
prepared.
There are those out there for sure.
There were also some slops like I've seen some guys that are there,
a cop.
I'm like,
Bro,
you can't run up block.
Fuck.
Are you a cop?
Yeah.
You know,
like this is a ridiculous position for you to put yourself in and anybody else.
You're trying to protect your handicap by Gluttony,
you know?
But,
but at the same time,
we do need them.
We need need,
need the cops because we need them to be more respected and appreciated.
They're not very respected and appreciated by a lot of people.
I think that's a,
and see what a huge miss service.
What I hate about this conversation,
whatever side they're on with the cops are gonna pull whatever they want because
we've talked negative or not negative.
We said some things about,
and I hate how we're in such a polar place where,
Oh,
you're either form or against it and that's like with everything and that's what
I hate.
You can't have a conversation anymore and that's where we're at right now.
It's like you can't say anything wrong with cops because then you don't support
the cops.
If you support the cops,
then you'll get attacked by the other side going,
oh well they kill innocent people.
I know.
And someone can take a clip of anything that you've said today without further
elaboration because most of what you said,
you further elaborate.
Absolutely.
They could take that one snippet and just put a little clip up somewhere.
Michael Yo said this,
or worse yet quoted,
this is what he said about cops.
We look,
fuck him.
I thought he was pro cup.